Hello everyone! I'm Alicia Malone
This is Fandango's Indie Movie Guide
There are so many indies out this week but I wanna concentrate on two of them
These two movies are so brilliant, so absorbing...
and are definetly gonna end up on my "Best" list of 2016
Enough teasing Malone!
Ok, fair enough. Let's get into it with 'Moonlight'
-*Clip* -Why you're looking at me like that?
-Like what, man? Come on, you just drove down here...?
-Yeah...
Before I even get started with this one I'm gonna put a big "awards watch" off the top
because this definitely deserves it.
You may have heard me talking about 'Moonlight' in my episode I did from TIFF
But just as a reminder
'Moonlight' is directed by Barry Jerkins, and it tells the story of one man's life in three different parts
So first you start up with him as a child, then you jump to him as a teenager,
and then jump again to him as an older man
And he is dealing with so much stuff.
trying to find a father figure, his crack addict mother
getting beating up at school and also battleling with figuring out his own sexuality
-At some point you gotta decide for yourself who you wanna be
-Can't let nobody make that decision for you
'Moonlight' has this dreamlike, memory-type quality
and Barry Jenkins has crafted a beautifully understated
yet still emotionally epic and boundary-pushing story
I've said before that 'Moonlight' is kind of like a meditation of masculinity
and what I mean by that is that gently and poetically
explores the ideas of what it means to be a man
and the boxes you're supposed to fit in to,
or the act you're suppose to play
You know the strenght and the violence
can sometimes be a mask for what it's really happening inside, the inner emotional thermboil
*clip* -What's wrong?
-I'm good
-No, I'm seeing you ain't
Moolight is definitely #AliciaApproves
Try to see it if it's playing in your area
because this is the kind of small movie that
absolutely deserves our support
-I ain't see you like a dad
-It's not what I expected
-What did you expect?
Moving on to my other big recommendation this week
'The handmaiden' by the genious: Park Chan-Wook
So I would put an "awards watch" over this one
but because it would end up in the Best Foreign Language category at the Oscars
and for that to happen It would need to be submitted via South Korea
as being they're official entry
and South Korea has chosen 'The Age of Shadows' as their official entry
So... Oh, well... I'm sure it's way to controversial for the Academy anyways
because this is an erotic-lesbian gothic-heist thriller
Japanese-Korean movie
I saw this movie in Cannes and the crazy story kept me at the edge of my seat
for the full 2 hours and 45 minutes
It's also sumptously shot
It's gorgeous to look at,
almost fetishly film at some points
Yes, it is very erotic, so it definitely is R rated
Don't take your kids, don't go with your parents
The two lead momen are fantastic
and you know ever since 'Sympathy for Lady Vengeance'
Park Chan-Wook has really been focusing on these strong female central characters
and when I was at Fantastic Fest I got to sit down with the genius director himself
So, I wanted to know why he's changed his focus to women in the last few movies
By the way, I shot this interview myself... so apologies if it doesn't look that good
Take it away Park Chan-Wook
Can I get a woop-woop? No?
Ok, then
So to recap: my picks this week are the emotionally satisfying 'Moonlight' by Barry Jenkins
Or the twisty korean thriller: 'The Handmaiden' by Park Chan-Wook
Stay tune to the very end of this episode
to see my other 3 favourite films by Park Chan-Wook
All of these are available on FandangoNOW for you to watch at home
I'm Alicia Malone. I'll see you next week
Bye!